- Doing the right thing
is always the right thing.
Always and forever.
(hip hop music)
Hey Vlog,
this will be a good one.
Late Sunday night,
very rare for me to leave the family
but this is for a good cause.
Obviously, the devastation in Puerto Rico.
My family has spent a lot of time there,
I do a lot of business.
I've done a lot of business
with people from there.
Eytan here,
the owner of Hunt and Fish Club
(bell ding)
you've seen it
in different vlogs.
I haven't been here much lately.
But you've seen him in other vlogs.
Very friendly with Jorge
Posada and asked me to
be a major player and
so I decided to co-host.
Step up,
gonna be a lot of Vayner people tonight.
That'd be fun to interview
some of them, D-Rock.
And, just really,
any time you can do something
for a worthwhile cause
like,
as you guys know I don't tend to show
a lot of my charity, water,
Pencils of Promise work or
a lot of the other stuff I do
in the nonprofit world.
I kinda grew up in it.
I have a cynical point of view of it
'cause so many of my friends
leverage it to show that
they're a good person.
But it is a passionate part of my life,
and so,
I thought it'd be important.
As I'm talking about new things
and showing you guys different things,
I do feel a sense of responsibility
of showing this part as well.
Just a little bit.
Still won't push it.
I'm much more comfortable
slingin' my books and my sneakers
than kind of like,
the stuff I'm more proud of.
You know, like you guys
know a lot of this stuff.
But anyway, nonetheless,
fun stuff.
Looking forward to it.
Bunch of athletes in the building,
bunch of VaynerMedia
employees in the building.
That's a win-win situation.
Jets just lost to Tampa Bay,
so I'm a little bit bummed,
that pretty much officially
wraps up their season.
You know, but,
great trip, obviously as you guys know.
This is two days before
the sneaker launch,
probably air right after it.
So I just wanna,
I'll just pre-empt it.
I'll go a little future here.
I wanna thank everybody
who supported me on that,
and wished me a 42nd happy birthday.
And hopefully D-Rock will get some
rad, rad content.
Is Baban coming too?
- [Man] Nah, he's editing.
- He's editing.
Hopefully D-Rock will
capture some rad content.
(festive piano music)
Patience would probably be
the biggest thing that I would tell him.
- Really?
- Sure.
Mom and dad want him to do well,
and he wants to do well.
The reality is, he's a kid.
- Well no, this is my old one.
He's 22.
- He's a fuckin' kid.
- Yeah he's a kid.
- 22's a fuckin' kid!
- Okay!
- We're barely,
you know, it's hard
when you're the parent.
- Right.
- Because you want him to be
settled and in a good place
and you love him.
- Right.
- 22's a kid.
The cliche thing, like
a mom of a 22 year old
is worried about,
it's dramatically less of an issue
than I think you would realize.
- Really?
- Mm-hmm!
He could do,
both of those boys could
do nothing right to 30.
Nothing.
And still be kids.
The way I see the world,
there's so much opportunity, because
the world is completely misunderstanding
what's actually happening.
The entire world trades on Facebook,
Instagram and YouTube.
And then it feeds to everything else.
It's all happening in here.
This is the world.
There is nothing else.
What's up, Lev?
- What's up, Gary?
(bell ding)
- Good to see you, brother!
Just to see Sid, lookin' so sharp!
This is worth
the entire price tag!
(bell ding)
You look great.
- Thank you.
- You look great.
- How's everything with you, though?
- Real good.
Other than the Jets, my life is awesome!
- I know, man!
- Alright, D-Rock, I have bad angle,
bad angle for me.
(laughs)
I need the good angle!
- [Gary Vaynerchuk] You win,
and then everything else works out.
You know?
You guys hustlin'?
You got businesses goin' on?
What kind of business would you do?
- I'd be a baseball player.
- You'd be a baseball player?
Okay, who's your favorite player?
- Aaron Judge.
- Aaron Judge, makes sense.
What kind of business would you have?
- Musician.
Like who?
Who's your favorite musician?
- Green Day.
- Green Day?
- Yeah.
- That's a good fuckin' answer, my man!
I like that.
Same?
- Yeah.
- I love that.
You guys having fun?
- Yeah.
- Awesome.
Gotta tell the youth
that being a baseball
player and a musician
is not running a business.
Let's play a little
on the vlog,
let's do a little ABC.
Alright, vlog, in the comments,
do you prefer A,
B,
or C?
I'm gonna bid on some shit.
KD, I got you.
Double nickels, five 50.
- [Man] You're bidding.
- I'm bidding!
(bell ding)
- What are you bidding on?
- On the little KD jersey, you know?
- Really?
- Yeah!
He's a good entrepreneur!
He's a nice
basketball player.
- Let me get
you guys together!
- But he's a good entrepreneur.
Big shout out to Draymond Green.
One of my favorites.
Fun fact, I put Draymond on SnapChat.
(laughs)
(upbeat indie-pop music)
Like I always say,
you don't need to buy
my sneakers or books.
You do you.
I'm here to force you to do you.
How you doing, D-Rock?
- [D-Rock] Really good, how are you?
- Really well.
I don't give a fuck.
(laughs)
I actually really want to look like Yoda.
And I always have.
- Do,
or do not.
There is no try.
- Grapes, D-Rock,
grapes, grapes.
Don't worry, Jordan.
You will?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Thanks for coming!
- I sprained my ankle yesterday,
but,
we made it!
- Yeah.
- Doing what?
- Flag football!
- Called the game winning sites now.
- Make sure that makes the vlog!
(laughs)
I am so proud of her right now!
I don't know if I've ever been more
proud of a VaynerMedia employee than that!
- Yeah.
- I'm excited about tonight.
- This is awesome!
- This is awesome.
- We raised a lot of money.
(reflective piano music)
There's something I'd love to say
and I say it a lot, which is
doing the right thing is
always the right thing.
It's super simple,
but I think more than ever,
the people that are fortunate enough,
whether it's financial,
whether it's
there's a lot of people
walking around here
that have attention of others because of
the thing I'm passionate about
which is social media and
things of that nature.
Platforms,
I see a lot of amazing athletes and
incredible entrepreneurs
and business people.
I think, more than ever,
we need to be thoughtful about
putting our energy,
and I'm a very optimistic,
positive kind of dude.
And I think there's a lot
going on in the world.
And I think, look,
all of us want to do things
that are the right thing,
and you want to do things
that are authentic to you.
And so for me,
for me, visiting Puerto Rico so many times
from a family standpoint of doing business
with so many entrepreneurs there,
it was super easy.
Obviously,
when you text me if you told me
I had to go to Iowa and milk a cow,
I would do it.
But for me it's a little more interesting
when it's a little bit closer
and deeper to my heart.
It's also super fun for
me tonight specifically,
because so many of the people
from VaynerMedia are here.
And I want to send a huge
shout out to all of them,
because I love them so much.
(applauding)
And look, you know,
I'm just humbled to be here.
I appreciate the intro
and I appreciate the generosity from
everybody downstairs on the silent auction
and I know we have a live auction.
It just means a lot for
you guys to be here.
Sunday nights are not the most convenient.
Two weeks notice is not
the most convenient,
and just seeing so many
people go out of their way
to be here tonight means
a lot to all of us.
So thank you so much.
- We have brought more than 200 patients
that needed critical treatment to the U.S.
These patients needed chemotherapy,
they needed dialysis,
they needed respirators,
they needed oxygen.
We've taken supplies
in more than 13 flights to Puerto Rico.
But now, there's still a
lot more that we need to do.
And this is the process that's gonna
take a long time.
We need clean up, we need rebuilding.
And we need to build Puerto
Rico's economy back up.
And that's what we're
gonna do with the funds
that all of you have
graciously donated tonight.
And we're gonna continue to do that
until Puerto Rico comes back,
stronger than ever.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you so much.
Raised a lot of money tonight.
Really, really an amazing night.
- If you do stay 'til midnight,
Gary is going to milk an Omaha cow.
(laughs)
Right here
on this stage!
- [Gary] Live, live!
- With his feral, dignified
- Live!
- Tweeting hands.
- I will do it!
I will do it!
- You don't wanna do that
at this day and age.
(laughs)
- I'm thrilled to be like, business.
But when giving,
giving is giving.
You don't need the accolades.
And people blend the two.
(festive dance music)
(bell ding)
- What's happening?!
- It's important to you guys,
I'll make it important to me.
- Thank you.
- Vlog,
Krupa, the best!
(bell ding)
If you need a PR company,
this is your lady.
Link it up, give her love.
She's the best!
But it's execution, not idea.
- Everything you do,
it means a lot, dude!
- I appreciate that.
- You really changed my life,
for real though.
I know you hear it all the time,
but like,
the main thing you talk
about that I really fuck with
100 percent is self-awareness.
The realest shit ever.
Realest shit ever.
(piano and hand clapping)
(singing)
(bell ding)
(live R&B influenced pop music)
(live singing, piano and acoustic guitar)
(bell ding)
(optimistic pop music)
(screaming)
- Gary Fucking Vaynerchuk!
(audience cheers)
- Did I hear chess talk?
- [Man] Yeah, yeah!
- I'm trying, guys!
I'm fuckin' hustling!
(laughs)
I'm fuckin' working 24/7
trying to make it happen!
- [D-Rock] Having a good time tonight,
doing the right thing is
always the right thing?
- Yes.
It's true, D-Rock!
Doing the right thing is
always the right thing.
Always and forever.
Life.
Super fuckin' interesting.
See ya.
(reflective piano music)